so a lot of people are dying from drugs
they are taking
that are in fact fentanyl but disguised
as something else that's intentional
poisoning that's murder we personally
know someone who died on saturday doing
that exact thing not a drug addict
someone who took a prescription pill
that was in fact fentanyl and killed him
that's the story of so many americans
so who's doing this derek maltz is the
former head of the dea special
operations division in the city of saint
louis and joins us tonight mr melissa
thanks so much for coming on so you're
hearing and we've interviewed and which
know someone personally just died of
this
who is doing this and why is no one
stopping them from doing this
talking that's a great question thanks
for having me first of all the mexican
cartels are inundating our country with
these poisonous deadly fentanyl pills
and now today the dea administrator put
out a warning about all the rainbow
colored pills that they're seizing all
over the country but behind the scenes
you have the chinese communist party
that are looking to destabilize this
country by killing the kids it's that
simple and president biden today in
pennsylvania is out there at a political
speech and he finally mentioned the word
fentanyl after all these years now two
years almost he finally mentions
fentanyl when we have kids as young as
13 years old dying every day in their
houses around the country and the
parents just can't believe it they're
angry there's a rally tucker september
17th
in front of the white house with parents
from around the country they just cannot
believe this administration is ignoring
the worst
crisis we've ever had when it comes to
killing our kids who in america wants to
see 13 year olds dying in their bedrooms
it's insanity and it was very insulting
tucker that the president waited for a
political speech before the midterms to
talk about the death of our kids
so if the u.s government was sending
poison into mainland china and killing
tens of thousands of chinese citizens
the chinese government would say
something about it to us correct i mean
that would be a major
diplomatic
incident between our two countries why
are we saying nothing to china
well apparently they started to say
something and then after the trip to
taiwan what nancy police pelosi now the
chinese are saying they're not going to
help on all the precursor chemicals that
they're exporting from china they're now
sending they're using the cartels as the
proxies to do their dirty work to kill
americans they're sending the poisonous
substances in the internet and
everything like that but they're also
sending mass amounts of precursor
chemicals so the mexican lab operators
can operate their labs in mexico tucker
just so you know cbp has done a
phenomenal job the month of august
they're seizing millions of these pills
over the weekend six hundred and twenty
five thousand last week a hundred one
point six million pills in tractor
trailer earlier in august 1.1 million
pills they had a guy walking with a
crutcher crutches this week
or last week 14 000 pills in his
crutches coming in from the gallows
sinaloa cartel runs that sector
yeah well next week we're going to do a
segment what happens to people who are
arrested importing poison in the united
states that kills children are they
actually punished we're going to we're
going to find out well i'm off but
some of them are i think but i i s well
we're we're going to find out and we're
going to speak to you again and i
appreciate you coming on derek waltz
thanks so much thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight